Schon lange tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit daran fleisch im labor zu
produzieren stakes frikadellen oder braten essen ohne dass dafür ein tier sterben muss erste tests haben
im labor bereits funktioniert doch jetzt ist ein niederländisches forschungsteam ein riesenschritt weitergekommen und
prognostiziert dass sie schon in vier jahren künstliches fleisch im restaurant essen werden und es in spätestens sechs jahren
Im supermarkt kaufen werden doch die gewinnung ist mit
menschlichem vampirismus verbunden quasi wie wieso weshalb jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist wirklich papieren vor ein paar wochen war ich in einem veganen restaurant in paris und habe fleisch gegessen
Das schmeckte nicht nur wie schweinemedaillons auch die textur und alles fühlte sich so an und schmeckte wie
Schweinefleisch es war absolut köstlich
Und es war kein tierisches produkt enthalten und es wirklich überfällig kein fleisch mehr aus der massentierhaltung
zu essen die industrielle herstellung von fleisch ist nämlich extrem
schädlich für mensch und tier die tiere werden auf engstem raum gehalten werden voll gestopft
Mit medikamenten wie antibiotika und hormonen ihnen werden die stäbe oder schwänze gestutzt
Damit sie sich stressbedingt nicht selbst oder andere tiere verletzen der massenhafte einsatz von antibiotika fördert die entstehung von
antibiotikaresistenten keimen bei einer infektion können wir menschen dann nur noch eingeschränkt behandelt werden immer wieder gibt es dazu neue
schlagzeilen in den medien und nicht umsonst waren die weltgesundheitsorganisation who vor einer drohenden
medizinischen katastrophe auch für die umwelt bedeutet die massentierhaltung eine riesige katastrophe
denn
Um beispielsweise ein mastschwein heran zu ziehen braucht es fast eine million liter trinkwasser und zwar ganz allein
Um sein futter an verbauen gefüttert wird es hauptsächlich mit soja für dessen anbau
beispielsweise regenwälder in brasilien weichen müssen wir haben hier schon öfter mal darüber berichtet auch das grundwasser wird durch die massentierhaltung
verschmutzt und zwar mit nitrat durch die gülle werden die böden überdüngt große mengen an stickstoff lagern sich
im boden ab und sorgen dafür dass verschiedene tier und pflanzenarten sterben
und zuletzt wird auch der klimawandel durch die massentierhaltung
Gefördert denn in den medien von kühen und rindern entsteht methan und das ist als klimagas etwa
25 mal klimaschädlicher als co2
Die forschung auf der suche nach wirklich künstlichen fleisch ist jetzt ein ganzes stück weitergekommen
zitat wir wollen dass für die fleischindustrie sein was das autos kreditkarte kutsche war das sagt der chef des kalifornischen
Start up unternehmens mensch mit seiner firma ist vor einiger zeit tatsächlich gelungen was viele
forschungsteams weltweit vor ihn probiert hatten fleisch künstlich herzustellen
Herausforderung, im moment kostet ein kilogramm künstliches fleisch
32.000 euro im vergleich dazu ein kilo herkömmliches rindfleisch gibt es schon für unter zehn euro
Das auch keine gute entwicklung ist einer der investoren für das projekt jeweils übrigens bill gates die fleisch sucht
im labor funktioniert vereinfacht gesagt
So aus dem muskelgewebe von kühen werden stammzellen entnommen die dann auf einer, nährlösung
Wachsen sie entwickeln sich zunächst, zu muskelzellen und dann zur muskelfasern und unter dem mikroskop
Sind die dann tatsächlich nicht von dem muskelfaser geflecht eines realen stacks zu
Unterscheiden um einen hamburger zu formen braucht es etwa
20.000 solcher muskelfasern auch, im niederländischen maastricht gibt es ein
versuchslabor das hamburger lab vor vier jahren wurden hier die ersten künstlichen hamburger
Gezüchtet doch das fleisch bestand nur aus muskelfasern es enthält kein fett oder bindegewebe und es war viel zu trocken auch der
preis dieses künstlich hergestellten fleisches war unbezahlbar eine viertelmillion dollar nämlich für den bratlinge obst
da muss ich mal kurz gucken
das übersteigt mal eben mein budget seitdem ist das forschungsteam große schritte vorangekommen
Kommen, und es ist mittlerweile in der lage komplette das fleisch zu
komponieren die muskelzellen können mittlerweile beispielsweise aus myoglobin
produziert werden das ist der stoff der muskeln rot einfärbt und ihnen den typischen fleischgeschmack verleiht leicht nach blut und
metall eben auch die finanzierung ist nun gesichert unter den geldgebern ist beispielsweise
Ergeben würden der google mit aufgebaut hat auch wenn die experimente derzeit noch
Im labor laufen die technologie ist mittlerweile so ausgereift dass sie auch in größeren
reaktoren stattfinden könnte damit seinen hamburger für 10 bis 11 dollar realistisch
es auch noch etwas über mein budget in drei bis vier jahren wollen die niederländer ihr künstlich
hergestelltes fleisch auf den markt bringen erst einmal in den niederlanden selbst und in großbritannien
Und das ganze hätte sicherlich große chancen auf dem markt künstlich hergestelltes fleisch wäre für viele
Dieser probleme die lösung überhaupt doch es ist nicht alles so toll wie es auf den ersten blick klingt denn bisher wachsen die
Muskelzellen auf einer, nährstofflösung wie aus zucker
Mineralien vitaminen aminosäuren und aus dem serum des blutes von
Kälber füllten besteht da werden die forscherinnen und forscher quasi zu vampiren denn um das serum zu gewinnen wird das ungeborene
Kalb aus der gebärmutter der kuh geholt um ihm dann blut aus dem herzen abzusaugen
Ja das geschieht ohne betäubung das kalb überlebt diese eingriffe nicht die kuh wird danach geschlachtet
Ja
zum anderen beinhaltet das ganze auch ein gewisses risiko denn das serum könnte krankheiten übertragen
Und so sind forschungsteams weltweit auf der suche nach alternativen eine basis könnte beispielsweise
Könnten pflanzen wie algen extrakt um bakterien seien dennoch wird labor fleisch immer zu einem teil aus tierischen rohstoffen
Bestehen aus den stammzellen doch die forscherinnen und forscher hoffen dass sich diese unter den richtigen bedingungen
immer weiter vermehren und so kontinuierlich neues muskelfleisch produzieren hochrechnungen von niederländischen forscherinnen und forscher zufolge
könnten dann
150 rinder die ganze weltbevölkerung ernähren
1,5 milliarden tiere sind es im moment ja das ist wirklich wahnsinn doch damit wäre tatsächlich in naher zukunft künstliches fleisch
im restaurant und in supermärkten kaufen können müsste noch einiges passieren
Zum einen müsse die infrastruktur noch ausgebaut werden um die produktion überhaupt erst einmal effizient
Zu machen die zucht müsste von den kleinen petrischalen in größere bioreaktoren da werden ja und im besten fall
Müsste dann auch geguckt werden dass nicht so viel energie verbraucht wird eine bedingung dafür wäre dass entsprechende startups finanziell gefördert werden und labor fleisch
müsste von den zuständigen behörden in der eu als neuartiges lebensmittel
bewertet werden sicherlich kein
einfaches unterfangen das könnte ein bisschen dauern dann gäbe es noch eine weitere aufgabe das künstlich hergestellte fleisch
Gesellschaftlich zu etablieren um fragen aus den usa
Und auch europa zeigen dass sie endlich 20 bis 50 prozent der leute fleisch aus dem labor probieren würden fest steht jedenfalls
Mit der konventionellen fleischproduktion
Geht es nicht mehr so lange weiter wie bisher die ressourcen sie dafür gebraucht
Werden die reichen schon bald nicht mehr aus und vielleicht ist hier ein weg gefunden worden
Diese katastrophe für mensch umwelt und tiere zu beenden bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf dem laufenden
Zu diesem thema wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dadurch mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit top sieben tiere auf drogen
der sehr lustiges video draufklicken und ablachen würde ich mal sagen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran